while the president fell short of his
vaccination goal earlier this month the
delta variant has quickly spread across
america and it now accounts for 83
percent
of our new coveted cases all of this
leading some states to reimpose mass
orders even for people who were
vaccinated a move
which is drawing very sharp criticism
from some
republicans i get a little bit
frustrated
when i see some of these jurisdictions
saying
even if you're healthy and vaccinated
you must wear a mask because we're
seeing increased cases understand what
that message is sending to people who
aren't vaccinated
it's telling them that the vaccines
don't work i think that's the worst
message you can send to people
at this time so i think it's real simple
there should be no mandates there should
be no vaccine mandates there should be
no mass
mandates we should respect individual
liberty now when it comes to vaccines
i believe in vaccines but i also believe
in individual liberty
and responsibility
you know jesse one of my big problems
with where the white house in particular
is on
this is that their messaging is like
thick mud
it's so unclear it's a very good analogy
i i i can't understand where they're
coming from
if they start saying that we need to
wear masks if we're vaxed
backs americans are not going to
backslide into that kind of mandate
cases are up a smidge harris but deaths
are
way down in fact the month of july
we've averaged less than 300 deaths a
day it's the best stretch we've ever had
so this is really a way
to just get unvaccinated americans to
wear a mask but it's just at the expense
of vaccinated americans
right now in this country we're at a
point where if he puts this back on
there's going to be a rebellion the
sheriff in l.a county is not even going
to enforce it
i'm in la this weekend and they're
telling me i'm going to have to wear a
mask
no one's going to be able to recognize
me harris it's going to be a huge blow
to the ego
but there's already been studies that
say that states without mask
mandates fared just the same as states
with
and now they're saying that if you're in
an elementary school situation
children have to wear a mask it's
preposterous
they're not spreading it in any
substantial way in fact it actually
hurts childhood development
it hurts socialization and the kids
can't even breathe
i understand you've got to get
vaccinated i got the j and j
only because it was one shot i'm afraid
of needles i only needed one
and now i feel like there is no pandemic
i can go around my parents grandparents
and i just forgot about the whole thing
so if you're unvaccinated
get the vacs but if you're dead set
against it there's only so far you can
push
there is i guess medical liberty in this
country
but at a certain point you just have to
give up now joe biden's doing something
very disturbing
he's basically blaming delta on
conservatives but that's not the case
right now the people that aren't being
vaccinated are people that are
apolitical
totally removed from the political
spectrum in this country
and actually it's 20 and 30 year olds
that aren't being vaccinated
and then racially black and hispanic
americans are less likely to have the
vaccine than white and asian americans
so how does he square that with saying
oh
if you are a migrant who is unvaccinated
i'm just going to let
hundreds of thousands of unvaccinated
migrants into this country and then bust
them
all throughout the interior that makes
no sense
at all wow you have really thought about
this
i have surprisingly one of the things
kaylee i i
well for somebody who's afraid of
needles and you know what the
transparency that you come forth with
jessie is really really amazing
um and i i you have so many friends here
that we would have held your hand
[Laughter]
but but you know what i'll tell you
where i've heard some of that from
it's from kaylee mcinerney and she was
there in the white house when they were
coming up with these vaccines and she's
talked with the very
high profile medical professionals who
were there
making the decisions so i want to come
to you kaylee with this in mind
how much damage is the white house doing
right now by not first of all being
often in concert with the cdc
sometimes they're in conflict with it
and right now we're waiting to see what
they're going to say
are they going to be the same or are
they going to make it as clear as the
cdc did and said
at this point we don't have any reason
to change the guidance but we're
constantly looking at the data
on math squaring exactly for me some of
the greatest reasons
if not the biggest reason for vaccine
hesitancy
is people like dr fauci we all remember
the math
saga they don't work oh wait they do but
i was just trying to save them for
medical professionals now you need to
mask okay
if you're vaccinated joe biden tells us
on may 13th of this year
you don't need a mask but now all of the
reporting tells us that the white house
is considering a return to mass we know
in some democrat jurisdictions
their returning to mass mandates was
totally contrary to the science we were
told
in the rose garden from president biden
on may 13th and harris
you mentioned the cdc i'm young enough
to remember last year
when president trump was derided
for quote dictating cdc guidelines on
schools and on
churches uh no he was in line with the
science but now you have joe biden
standing on a stage last night saying we
might require masks for those 12
and younger the cdc saying we're not
changing our guidelines
where are the stories joe biden
pressures the cdc
contrary to the science which says
children don't spread this
and don't spread at the same level as
adults and aren't affected in the same
way as adults that's the science go to
harvard.edu
but here you have joe biden dictating
a scientific messages to the cdc where
is the outrage
uh miranda devone
hi harris look the problem with the
advice that's coming out of the white
house
is that their motive is purely political
they are constantly
politicizing this issue about covert
whether it's masks or vaccines
they're using it to do their favorite
thing which is demonizing trump
supporters trump voters that's the only
way they can see that they can win
next year in the midterms so they're
going to let every post be a winner for
them
regardless of the fact that if you go
and tell vaccinated people
that they have to wear masks and go
through
all the restrictions that we had when
the pandemic was at its height
you are completely removing any reason
for people to get vaccinated
and every american can see what's going
on down at the southern border
where you've got people streaming over
who are not
vaccinated who have got raging covert
infections
and then they're being shipped all over
the country
covertly uh in the dead of night they're
being flown into places like louisiana
into small communities
and dumped there it's not fair to them
and it's certainly not fair to the
communities
you know americans have been locked down
have suffered
enormously through the pandemic we've
come through the other side
with these amazing vaccines that have
completely unhitched
death and illness and hospitalization
from cases we shouldn't be looking at
cases anymore
i love when you talk you use verbs like
unhinged
i mean that is just amazing let's hear
real quickly from dr marty mccary
professor at johns hopkins university
school of medicine last hour on the
faulkner focus
watch and then emily i'm coming to you
our battle is not against the sniffles
it's against
death and disability and overrun
hospitals and if we have a powerful
tool that downgrades the infection to a
seasonal mild common cold like illness
that's not something that we need to
change society for
emily that's exactly right the initial
purpose of the social distancing and
quarantining and masks
were so that we didn't overwhelm the
medical system which as the at this
point
is totally equipped to handle now this
not only new variant but
also the slight upticks in positive
cases given the high vaccination rate
we've experienced in this country
i have to point out as well the totally
unsurprising hypocrisy from that
group of rogue texas democrat oh sorry
not rogue
fugitive and brave texas democrats that
few
flew masculists on that private flight
and now are enjoying a 1.5 million
dollar stay in dc
and now they're calling for yes
universal mask wearing
you guys don't forget what happened to
for example gavin newsom when he was
called out for enjoying that french
laundry dinner and he said
i'm human we're all human we all fall
short sometimes in his maya culpa
remember the michigan governor michelle
widmer who said
she threw the dinner party and when she
was called out she said i'm human
i made a mistake so i'm just waiting for
one of these guys to come out with the
apology now that they're all positive
and they've been
infecting part of the white house but
just remember as well
my favorite part is michelle beckley who
the final plea of hers to get more
twitter followers
where it just goes to show they are
abdicating their duty just for that
social media shine
real quickly and we do have to go fast
jesse waters you said something that i'm
sure people
are really really leaning in for you
said
you know these are not the people who
are conservative
who don't want to get vaccinated i don't
want to put words in your mouth but say
it again
well i read a study that said a lot of
the people that aren't vaccinated
they're not republican they're not
democrat they're totally removed from
the political
realm and detached basically
they don't watch the news they don't
follow it they're not registered to vote
even
and those are the people that you have
to reach it's not the conservative
ideologues
primarily that are driving the
unvaccinated and delta strains
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe
right now